you a kayaker whoever said that over
there Oh tell you what I'm gonna combine
that root canal kayaking that is
serendipitous in its beauty root canal
kayaking is great someone over here
shows up what do you share umbrellas now
it's kind of boring misogyny yes
misogyny and root canal kayaking a hand
up in oxbow lake Oh get you job every
teacher
yes oxbow lake root canal kayaking
misogyny let's get to more
you said paper with such enthusiasm do
who said paper and he said paper what do
you have a particular favorite type of
paper
Jesus GSM the GSM of Playford yes the
GSM of paper root canal kayaking
misogyny hey it's me I fast forwarded
this part of the video because they were
really rowdy and it took them such a
long time to come up with another
suggestion while I have you do me a
favor like the video comment on it it is
so helpful and I really appreciate it
also if you're interested in merchandise
head over to good sir la calm because I
will be launching that really soon you
can put your email in and I'll let you
know when the pre-sales are open cool
enjoy the video
Arabic Botox I mean I'm not entirely
sure how sensible that is as a choice
Arabic Botox misogyny root canal
kayaking oxbow lakes and the GSM of
paper those of those will do those are
our five okay by the way guys you were
so [ __ ] rowdy in that section just so
you know every other audience puts their
hands up and takes it in turns so you
brought this on yourself
this what its gonna be as a freestyle
rap that is a rap night upon the spot
based entirely on those suggestions he's
not prepared is not pre-written is not
scripted it will never be seen again it
will be about root canal kayaking
misogyny oxbow lakes Arabic Botox and
the gsm-r paper and don't worry it will
not be anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly toe-curling ly bad as you
are expecting a private
educated middle-class white boy to be
let's drop that beat good sir let's have
fun a pain in my mouth and it swells at
the bottom of my incisor need a canal
dug down by the dentist sitting in the
chair whirring my fingers crossed when
he drills there you know I feel the pain
he takes out the nerve he puts it to the
nurse the assistant they serve it was an
injection numbing my gums and then he
pulls our roll and he's having some fun
I say dentist man where the [ __ ] is that
is this a canoe no it's a kayak it's
about the same way from the front of the
back now open wide and put your head
back he dives down my throat and into
the tooth admittedly this is fantastical
or truth and making it up I'll say it
again you might be thick like a large
gsm that's the thickness of the paper
Graham square meter if you're in
stationery this might be easier
I see the stack of the paper there but
if you want it in a copy err you gotta
get it more on the eighty side but if it
wants to be hard
then card provides a much better one
it's hard like lightning and thunder
you wanna card 400 that's the perfect
thickness the perfect wing if I wanna be
pretty wise my wish my lips to be thick
like an Armenian I want blunt mouth like
Khloe Kardashian but I will say this I
really really need it I get surgery done
right down in Egypt
in Guerra to stop a say mr. Egypt
timi brotox' he lies me down upon the
couch with the injection he put her over
there such fun lipo section as well
improves all the shape around my chin
I'm such an attractive dude when I get
my epidermal filler I'll be going hard
like my rib dish and Scylla a classical
reference the a might spit I never win
geography I never miss any fact I never
make a mistake the river overflows makes
an oxbow lake it used to be a curve then
it [ __ ] went overflow its banks all
the sediment built up over time it was
unpleasant
why is left water in the shape of a
present gradually the river goes down
with my hand there is straight
it's got no meander lasting are often no
apology for putting makeup in no
misogyny from me I don't hate women at
all as long as they are on their knees
and the sucking my balls now thank you
well that is what you like I knew you
wouldn't run my Senate life psyche yeah
darling gamble Boober with the wrists
see this tattoo
it's less feminist that is what you
really gotta do today
prove your bona fides to get a bj if
they see that wow they're so pleased
they're saying are you circumcised with
no dick jeez it's a callback to before
I've come like the river feel a age
Acula it goes with the quiver no oxbow
lake with the semen dies horrible come
up up on the ceiling what
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]